Sign up, pick up the spirits.
And let's hear from SIDA Farsi, who is, as you know,
a member of the house of Lords para ness, no less from, uh,
one of your favorite people. David Cameron,
what's he doing now as he was the first Muslim cabinet minister,
first Muslim chair of the conservative party first, um, in many,
many ways to do many things.
He's a prominent campaign of Islamophobia and against racism.
So she is going to lift our spirits and tell us the truth
at last.
Well, good evening, ladies and gentlemen, water, ridiculous motion.
There's nothing. There's not much great about Britain.
It is a nonsense,
and that is why I urge you to listen carefully to my submissions and vote
against this motion tonight.
This is what's great about Britain, this amazing city, this
multicultural audience,
you an audience that has turned out on a bitterly cold
night and has paid yes, paid I'm shocked,
paid to listen to those two miserable moves over there
telling you what a hole we live in. Right?
I asked you to oppose this motion and that's where I start.
What's great about Britain is our quirky pastimes.
Our ability to listen politely when we disagree,
our dry self-deprecating sense of humor. We are a serious nation,
but we don't take ourselves very seriously. We wear as a badge of honor,
our ability to do ourselves down because deep down we know we have
nothing to prove when we don't just tolerate,
but celebrate great thinkers.
Those have perfected moaning to a form of art.
Ladies and gentlemen, it's been on display tonight. I asked you to reject it.
The fact you came here, we discuss what we do.
We leave and call home where we choose.
We pray to whom we wish, and we love who we desire.
You may say these are basics, but basics,
which as a whole are simply not true of most nations.
And yes,
there's the issue of values and democracy and the rule of law and free
speech and freedom of association and privacy. And I could go on and on.
And crate was brilliant at outlining some of that.
And as someone who has lived in cultures where overdramatic
reactions, high emotions are part of everyday discourse,
I'm clad that reality TV in the UK is just a pastime are not
aware of life. I say,
what makes us great is that we're a country of steady eddies,
not a nation of drama Queens.
It's what underpins our world-renowned diplomatic service,
how even in the ex colonized nations,
we still command a hearing. And it's where in international fora,
our advice is still sought and still heard.
And I had the privilege of serving our country,
serving as a foreign office minister and have lost counts of the number of
times.
We were asked for our unique British perspective in our unique
British way,
branded in Ellie report last year as a truly global power. Second,
only to the us,
it said that we have a unique capacity to project and extend
ourselves around the world with a particularly strong performance in relation
to diplomatic leverage. And yes, we may be leaving the UK in my view,
a bad decision,
but it's one top table of many that we sit on as head of the Commonwealth,
a member of the permanent five at the UN security council,
a member of the G seven, the sixth largest economy in the world,
despite being less than 1% of the world's population. We,
and this was for you, Peter.
Cause I know you love this phrase were punching above our weight on the
international stage as we do in shorts,
as we do in sports, we ranked third in the world for rugby.
You heard from Kate second in the Olympic metal league first in cricket.
And yes, we may fall down all nations in terms of our national football teams,
but we still have the best football league anywhere in the world.
There's only Morgan said when we won the cricket world cup last summer,
ladies and gentlemen, Allah is definitely with us and in the arts,
Shakespeare is the unrivaled King of theater and we have an
alphabet of great letters. Gentlemen, can you name them? A is for Austin.
B is for my favorite blights and C is for Chaucer.
D is for Dickins E is for Elliot.
We could go right down to Z and we would still have people to name from
Lawrence of Arabia to Gandy.
We tell other people's stories better than they do from the railway children to
train spotting.
We beautifully defined and redefined the coming of age moments through
film. And we may not rival Marvel and star Wars,
or we could close second with Harry Potter and Mr. Bond.
yMusic the beacons still rank as the top selling band of all times.
And we dominate the top 10 with led Zeppelin pink Floyd, Elton John,
and even today with Adele and ed Sheeran and ladies and gentlemen,
we have Yorkshire. We have God's own County,
that little nation within a nation with its stunning landscapes. The pen Hines,
the malls, the historic towns, the quirky villages,
Betty's cream cakes rub alongside Bradford,
the authentic Curry capital of the world and tea tea,
ladies and gentlemen,
it may have been discovered in the East Peretz Yorkshire that perfected a brew
and you share,
and Britain is where this daughter of an immigrant millworker
broke tradition and taboos to become Britain's first Muslim cabinet minister.
And that as a conservative and years later,
as I publicly and forcefully objected to government policy and
resigned,
I knew that I could have my say and walk away without the
fear of a bullet in the back of my head,
a certain outcome in many nations around the world.
We simply take these things for granted.
We take for granted that we have non rip-off black cabs that we can arrive in
Heathrow, get in a cab and we will arrive safely with a fair fair,
we have free schooling. We have free healthcare.
We have world leading universities and cutting edge research.
We have a largely non-corrupt police force operating within without fear
or favor.
And we have an armed force who embrace a human rights
framework,
even when operating in the harshest of environments on which for
over a hundred years.
And I'm proud that both my paternal and maternal grandfather were prepared to
serve for great Britain, a country that they had not even seen.
And this great armed force has been made up of people of all faiths
and all races. Yes, including seeks, can somebody send Laurence Fox,
the bloody memo and even our,
whether we have the blessings of seasons and yet most often
it may be mediocre weather, but you know what,
a time of climate change and extreme climates, I say, thank God for mediocre.
And finally language ladies and gentlemen, English,
the world's language of choice, the language of trade,
the language of dispute resolution, the language of diplomacy.
500 years ago, 5 million people spoke English today.
It's over 2 billion.
A quarter of the world's population speak the language of a
country of just over 50 million.
And if for no other reason than just this makes us not just
great, but pretty spectacular. In fact,
the only thing that's really rubbish about great Britain is the rubbish.
And so if we clean up our streets and country verge as a neighborhoods,
we will not only address one of my biggest irritants,
but we could be the cleanest as well as the greatest nation on earth.
So ladies and gentlemen, I asked you to reject the motion today.
And if in that typically British way after my,
and Kate's submissions,
you feel pangs of sympathy for the underdogs on the other
side don't will.
And Peter I've done all right tonight.
They've had a fabulous moaning therapy session
and they've made you pay for it. Thank you.
[Inaudible].